I was on Twitter the other day I was
scrolling on Twitter and I you know I I
try not to do that but I do it's
addictive it's not as addictive as Tick
Tock which is the problem The Tick Tock
algorithm they say is the most addictive
but Twitter is you know now it's it's a
little more fun now than it was you know
it's always been crazy
um that's why I I go through it and I I
came across these kids that were yelling
about Biden
um and Twitter's you know they're like
young dudes screaming about Biden about
that they love Biden it's hilarious it
almost felt like trolling but it wasn't
that they love Biden and the Gen Z is
gonna let Biden and and all that stuff
and usually on Twitter it's the little
Nazi kids that are always chirping about
how like the band you know their band
teacher made them trans again or
something else which I don't may or may
not be true but it's usually that's the
contingent that I see a lot I guess
maybe that's who follows me or whatever
um but I saw these kids and I thought it
was like a joke
um and I've been trying to get David
Hogg on the show we tried to get David
hog in the show David Hogg will not come
on the shot I don't know what he's
afraid of but or maybe he just you know
loathes me I don't know
um
but I'm watching these freaks right and
they're just screaming and yelling about
Biden and gen Z and I invited them on
the show
and I have to say I'm pleasantly
surprised that that they you said yes
and you're here yeah of course in L.A
for some odd reason and you're here and
you're and you're you're doing it yeah
and you were told not to do it by a lot
of people yeah that's right but you know
just having fun kind of yeah
what's the deal with you because
everybody says you're like paid by the
DNC everybody says your shells right or
a lot of people not everybody but
there's a a group of people on the
internet saying that because you guys
scream at your phone you're very
passionate videos about that you love
Biden who's a man of what 70 years your
senior how old is he he's
80 now I think he's 80. can you move the
mics closer if you're gonna be that
quiet I mean you've never been that
quiet in your life oh sorry okay loud
now all you do is yeah now you're not
like soft-spoken and quiet and
considerate or you literally all you've
done is free and now this is the first
time you're [__] so Biden's what how
old is she he's like yeah he's like 80 I
think he's 80. yeah and you're how old
I'm 20. so he's 60 years that's right
older than you but okay so a lot of
people in the Trump World he's older too
yeah
um are you guys paid DNC chills no no
that's just like a conspiracy that's
been crafted on on Twitter specifically
in the recent days
um that we've received money from the
DNC we've never received money from the
DNC if the DNC was paying people we
should be first in line
yeah because you do you you put out all
of these videos all the time you should
get money yeah I mean go get if you're
not getting money go get mine and we've
received zero dollars from the DNC for
it and like I don't know it's just been
a crazy couple of days as you've seen
it's been like 70 million views on this
story and for us it's just a little
frustrating because you know like real
issues going on there's actual things
affecting Real Americans and we're
trying to like talk about that stuff
we're not trying to talk about the DNC
paying people which is not even real
when did you get into this why did you
why do you care so much I've always
found that the a declining society and I
think the great Anna has should have
read scare said this a a society really
starts to crumble when women and young
people get involved in politics politics
should be for kind of you know boring
men in Gray suits and when women and
young people feel the need it's like the
Hitler Youth right when women and young
people get involved it's a problem so
why do you got you keep screaming about
what did gen Z should be involved why
should gen Z get involved in anything
well to be honest like two two creepy
men approach me and knocked on my door
five months ago and they were like we'll
give you x amount of money yeah no um I
don't know I just to be like gen Z's you
know different we've never seen America
in like real peace right we were born
after 9 11 we got into the war on terror
we've had like three recessions right
and so like a lot of us are just very
passionate because it feels like we're
getting [__] all the time just [__]
all all I can say is I have I have
sympathy for the school shooting thing
of course that I that I I'll listen to
you guys on that all the other issues
I'm not that I'm not willing to listen
to you guys because I understand that
you are getting shot in school yeah and
that's many of you can't handle that
you're not tough enough to handle it so
I don't understand why that bothers you
but like do you understand how your
content can be cringy when like like I'm
looking at it and you're literally like
jensy's gonna step on your [__]
throat Joe Biden's cup like you
understand that it's a why do you choose
to do it like that
I don't know it's bad like in hindsight
some of it's very cringe right but like
I don't know maybe I'm just a cringy guy
like I'm just passionate I just turn on
the camera and I just start screaming
about what I'm passionate about and I
just post yeah trying to like convey to
the audience the severity of the issue
and the passion we have around it so
like I've screamed a lot about like you
know AR-15s and how I think we should
ban them like the fact that makes people
really upset it makes people really
upset older people get really angry and
then they send you photos with their
AR-15 yeah and then you know I've gotten
a lot of people telling me that they've
bought more AR-15s because of me like
they're just freaks Harry sisson's
driving sales available yeah yeah you're
actually making the holes apparently I'm
making the gun making it worse okay
yeah I mean I just like as you said like
on school shootings for example like you
know we've said this in our videos that
you know our generation and young people
are like traumatized by gun violence
sure you know we can't go to schools
movie theaters malls without thinking am
I next or but you understand when there
are people that the guns are not only a
part of their culture but it's the way
that they feel like they protect their
family I I think there should be more
restrictions on guns too I agree with
you but there are people for example
that you know feel that those guns are
necessary to secure their freedom uh in
the sense that you know I mean look what
a few years ago we had riots in most
major American cities that for two
months went on you know we had crazy
[__] going on and then you know we had
people saying let's defund and abolish
police so that you know the idea of
people having weapons and even AR-15s a
lot of people think that it may be
necessary because things might
degenerate further
I I mean I don't know I think that's
it's like catastrophizing that you know
the United States right I think like
that's the new name of the show
catastrophizing the United States
it seems it seems a little extreme like
why can't we just start with like you
know like 95 of Americans agree with
like Universal background checks like
why can't we just start there I'm not
opposed to more regulations or
restrictions I'd have to get into the
weeds of what they would be but I don't
necessarily disagree with you there I
disagree with some a lot of the other
stuff that you guys say but not all of
it 100 I don't disagree with every like
I I've always said if I spoke to Isis I
would agree with a lot of what they said
if I sat down with Isis and they made
points I go well that won't make sense I
get it
um but why did you become so impassioned
about politics at a young you've been
making videos Harry for how long like
three years now and it's been it's
literally been five months for me and
it's been five months for a year five
months yeah I mean I think that you know
as young people we're more connected to
the the world than ever you know we've
earned we have our phones and there's
news everywhere and just reading a lot
of it I'm like I feel like I can't just
like sit here and do nothing like I feel
like I have to get involved and you know
what's the best way to get involved
right now and make a message heard
social media and yeah I mean it's it's
like at the end I don't think other
people realize like it's all Trump right
Harry and I like very much a lot of this
political field is just we all looked at
the TV at like 15 years old we saw
Donald Trump lying all the time 24 7.
he's a freak and we just got super
passionate about like this is not the
direction we can go and so at the end of
the day like it's actually Trump do you
not think
that most if not all politicians bend
the truth not to certain themselves yes
but not like Donald Trump I do think
Trump I talked about it I've talked
about this extensively it's like Trump's
on a whole new propaganda level it's
disgusting well there's a lot of people
that would say that
the American government for a very very
long time uh has been very dishonest
with its citizens this is something that
can you give me an example can I give
you an example dude that was stupid
well of course it happens but like but
but what I'm saying to you is like I you
can make it all about Trump if you'd
like but there's a lot of people uh that
you know feel that when you guys you you
you're you're very it very much seems
that when you're talking it feels a
little North korea-ish you feel like
you're oh you're just talking about one
side right and you're saying and I don't
know I've never seen a video of you guys
criticizing Democrats I've never seen a
video of you guys being introspective at
all you know in the sense that like you
know it just seems like you're
cheerleaders for one side instead of
going hey I'm a young guy I want to be
involved and I'm I'm passionate about
this but like yeah maybe our side isn't
perfect uh in this way and that way yeah
I mean mean to be honest like it's it's
actually really hard in the space right
like we have like 45 seconds to record a
video keeping people's attention and a
lot of people on our side like if they
start hearing like I've actually done it
before I've criticized like a Democrats
like specifically Hakeem Jeffries and it
it all just went South like I started
losing followers like it's bad right and
I really want to be that person that
like reaches the other side because
Democrats I mean they're horrible at
their jobs right they do a lot of shitty
things although I'll vote for them all
the time but it's also hard in the space
to criticize that's a good can we clip
that quote please
don't please don't please don't clip it
um
I would say the same I would say the
same thing about most Party Machine
politicians I would say I don't think
you're wrong I think it's the lesser of
two evils argument that people have had
forever what you just said is pretty
much where the American people are a lot
of people think Democrats and
Republicans are both horrible at their
jobs and they the people that vote for
them are still going to vote for them
based on whatever self-interest they
they have have I'm not I don't think
that's actually that crazy
um what I think though is like when
you're so young and you're yelling and
you have people that have had so much
more life experience and you you can
imagine how it looks to to people that
are older and you know they they see you
guys and they go these kids I mean even
though you're not kids or adults you're
young men but they go they don't [__]
have any idea what they're talking about
maybe Harry you obviously are from you
know from Langley Virginia you have a
little bit more but then Chris they
found you in like a Waffle House people
I had no idea George Shores ate in
Waffle House the point is like dude so
what do you guys do I go on Twitter
sometimes and you and the the little
Maga freaks you guys all yell at each
other and stuff for four hours a night
shouldn't you be doing drugs and getting
laid isn't that more fun than screaming
about Kamala Harris
isn't this a weird way to spend your
young adulthood it is the human truths
are so much deeper uh than just politics
whenever I see somebody like it's all
the same type of freaks and it's just
young guys in suits with these vacant
looks in their eyes and they got a photo
with Trump or a photo would bite him and
and you're all just yeah and I guess
it's necessary because that's the next
generation of [__] people that are
gonna come and ruin the country
but you know what what are you what give
me the what what's the pitch for Joe
Biden oh man I mean do you want me to go
down the list go down the list all right
I won't go into detail in each one but I
think generally his presidency has been
incredibly successful in terms like one
of the most productive presidents in
modern American history undoubtedly the
American Rescue plan the bipartisan
infrastructure deal of the bipartisan
safer communities act the PAC deck the
chips act the inflation reduction act
rejoining the Paris climate Accord
rejoining The Who historic judicial
nominees first black woman on the
Supreme Court the child tax credits
first black woman on the Supreme Court
what like I'm that's good I mean but
she's also like aside from that but just
putting an extremely qualified nominee
on the Supreme Court I mean okay but say
that well I think it's a combination of
this you say like a first black woman
who's an amazingly
qualified you know and we spoke and I
just otherwise we're just checking boxes
it doesn't seem to make sense well I've
spoken to her qualifications but what
like the point is there is that she is
obviously far more qualified than any of
the nominees that Trump put on so it's
like do you want qualified people like
political ideology aside do you want
qualified people or do you just want
people who are going to rule Kavanaugh
is qualified Amy coin Barrett's
qualified you may disagree with them Amy
Connie Barrett is nowhere near as well
Jackson well listen well Define
qualifications in that sense just time
served like Amy Coney Barrett only had a
very short amount of time actually
serving as a judge whereas katanji Brown
Jackson had far more experience
um you know worked more in the field
prior to being a judge
um and her opinions were more consistent
like Amy Cooney Barrett had a lot of
like inconsistencies well now we're
politicizing it so yeah I'm just gonna
go with quote but whatever so all of
these things the chips act the American
Rescue plan that's right okay we we do
have massive inflation we have a we have
an economy that is by by I think the
admission of Democrats doesn't work for
everybody right I mean this is something
they keep you know what is Biden really
really done to help people who are
really struggling whose kids do not have
uh you know maybe enough food to eat or
you know like because it seems like a
lot of the same policies it's just a
very similar you know kind of
establishment Democrat middle of the
road guy I mean we we still have a lot
of people millions and millions of them
without health care right I mean we
still have you know we have vast chasms
of income inequality which I mean I
imagine will persist right
um Joe Biden has I mean has he done
anything to back down you know these
these Mega corporations from kind of
eating everybody I mean yeah like he you
know worked to cap insulin at 35 with
Eli Lilly right that was a big win for
like Pharmaceuticals okay uh
unemployment's the lowest it's been in
54 years inflation's gone down seven or
eight months in a row or whatever right
so I think it's like it's about the fact
that we're stepping in the right
direction and again comes back to the
point that like Trump and that like side
of politics is like not the right
direction like we need to start moving
toward same people and we can get to
fixing those issues aim to have a proxy
war with Russia in the Ukraine is it
saying to have a foreign policy that
pushes China and Russia closer together
is It Sane to isolate a country that has
more nuclear weapons than any other
country and push them into a direction
where their only friends or other
enemies of America you know other
totalitarian regimes you know are those
is that a sane foreign policy is that a
saying foreign policy I I would say that
is it a sane
uh cultural uh you know domestic policy
to say that children have a
constitutional right to puberty blocking
hormones
I mean to both of those things so like
which came out recently they're very
nuanced issues like they're very complex
yeah so yes four-year-olds having a
constitution
explain the Nuance not even but let's go
to the Nuance there's obviously more to
this the more to the the organizations
so in Ukraine yes we do I I mean I can't
speak for Chris but I have obviously
support uh the Nazis in the Ukraine no
no not there's bad people everywhere we
don't support that but we support but
those are the people fighting the war in
the Ukraine you know it was off
Battalion and a lot of their special
forces are avowed neo-nazis which is
okay listen let's just be honest honest
about it we're supporting those not we
like those Nazis they're the good night
it's not it's not that we want to
support Nazis it's that you know an
anti-democracy enemy is invading a
pro-democracy Ally didn't Ukraine ban a
lot of the pro-russian parties after the
last election is that Democratic weren't
there pro-russian parties in the Ukraine
and they were banned but that doesn't
feel like democracy to me the pro the
pro-russian parties were doing a lot of
harm in Ukraine now obviously like I
don't agree with that I'm not I'm not
here to you know be a spokesman but this
idea if you're if you want to talk about
Nuance which I love I love news me too I
love nuance and we're gonna say oh do
you think America is out there do you
think the American foreign policy is
about spreading democracy and securing
democracy I think it's more than just
like preserving democracy obviously I
don't think oh it's a lot more it's a
lot more but it's a lot more we don't I
don't I think it's in the United States
interest to not have Russia get stronger
and I think that's like at the core of
this like Ukraine has a lot of of raw
materials but Russia is becoming
now an ally and they've been pushed
together with China they were always
allies Russia yeah but this is now we've
isolated Russia they've now gone and
said who's our one friend oh our one
friend is China now there are you're
looking at this Eastern Alliance so I
agree with you obviously you don't want
to make Russia stronger but we've also
put Russia into a corner by supporting
the Ukraine the way that we have by not
going in there and urging any type of
peace deal we've put Russia in the
position of two outcomes one
they are demoralized and they leave the
country in defeat there's an almost
certain coup Putin's ousted he knows
that or that's they leave and say sorry
are bad or the second option they use
nuclear weapons or they continue to
fight in the Ukraine we've done nothing
to bring about any resolution here where
Russia can save face and we can have
some type of solution it seems like it's
a very foolhardy foreign policy to
isolate Russia in the way that we have
and basically give them two options
Absolute Total defeat or God forbid them
using a nuclear weapon or the
continuation of this war and the death
of more ukrainians well to be clear the
United States and Ukraine have reached
out to Russia to have peace talks yeah
like we've they've tried extensively and
I'm just trying to actually been
reported that we've discouraged no I
think I think that's no that's actually
incredibly reported that is that that
Source right I think Boris Johnson went
to uh Ukraine and talked to zielinski or
something well first of all we're the
United States NATO we are giving them
all the money we're giving them all the
weapons how hard are we pushing peace
talks if we're literally flooding the
country with we're not requiring them we
should literally say well you need to
have peace talks or we're not going to
fund this war with no endings I think
the idea was that we're not gonna like
start talking peace until Russia agrees
to you know stop just Mass murdering
civilians it's a war and that's
unrealistic you have to come to the
table right exactly well exactly so I
understand when you're talking about
sanity you say Donald Trump's a lunatic
I might agree with you but I see four
years of Donald Trump we're not in a lot
of foreign entanglements we're not on
the verge of a real problem with Russia
and China to be honest I'm seeing right
now this bellicose foreign policy led by
Neil Khan's warhawks who are now all on
the Democratic side Bill Crystal hates
Donald Trump all of these guys that
supported the Iraq War hate Donald Trump
there are now all a pirate chicks for
Biden's Administration they're on MSNBC
they are pushing War they are pushing
the continuation of not only this war
they're pushing maybe further conflicts
with China so to me when you talk about
sanity I say to myself that seems insane
but to be clear it's like the idea that
we're pushing Russia and China closer
together is not I don't think founded in
fact Russia and China have always been
close together and China have
specifically come out very publicly and
said that we disavow this we want Russia
to be peaceful we want an end to this
war now might there be more trade
possibly but I think that we can't just
sit while other countries are getting
invaded like if we just we're just like
well you know we don't really want to
get involved let's just have all these
American interests in the Ukraine and
what is our what is our Vital National
Security interest in the Ukraine what is
our Vital National Security I mean I
remember I'm old enough to remember when
people were going we don't really have a
vital National Security interest in Iraq
we shouldn't spend 20 years uh we're
defense contractors get rich and cities
like Detroit fall as you said we have
all of these problems domestically in
our country and these wars enrich a
small percentage of the population at
the expense of a lot of people in this
country that need help are those
billions of dollars that are going to
the Ukraine not better served in America
well I think that we can walk and chew
gum at the same time right so we can
address foreign policy while also
dressing addressing domestic policy in
places that really needs it and that's
why I think Joe Biden's been great he's
been able to do both at the same time
he's done neither because he's done more
domestically I think more if your or
your argument domestically he's done
more his foreign policy seems a little
bit like a mess I don't know if I think
they're going to make the same deal in
the Ukraine that they could have made a
year ago with a lot less Bloodshed and a
lot less deaths and if that happens it's
going to seem like we unnecessarily
helped prolong this conflict I don't
know if you think the Ukraine is going
to win this war it's it's going to be
like another five years of Bloodshed
yeah that doesn't actually
with a nuclear power
you know it's the way it's the I mean
it's the way the cars felt like like he
said Russia is you know invading a a
democratic State at the end of the day
what do you want to do just just not
involve ourselves we did that once you
know in the 40s and then you know
Germany was in on the beaches of Dunkirk
right so we just happened listen in the
very beginning we did involve us we did
a lot of we did sanctions we did this we
did that that's right what we are now
doing is we're now essentially fighting
a proxy war if if NATO is it's NATO
Weaponry uh that the ukrainians are it
gets very murky as to whether Russia and
NATO are fighting a war and so to me I
will drop both of you off in Poland
I will drop both of you off in Poland
and you can go and yell into and and do
your phones and be like Vladimir Putin
I'm here with the Nazis in the Ukraine
and you better watch out because we're
about to [__] you up gen Z doesn't care
that's why we're here in Keith and you
can do things with zelinski yeah I
actually like both of you I disagree
with you on a lot of things but I do
like you you're cool dudes
um uh I I think you're a little nuts I
think the content is a little much are
you planning on just doing this through
the entire election or just screaming in
your phone I think so I think I think
like there's room for
some equal projects so we don't we have
we we really don't even have it figured
out yet like what we're gonna do in 2024
but that's kind of the plan as of now
okay yeah just day by day man where can
people follow you I know everybody's
screaming yelling at you now but where
can they follow you if people want to
follow you if you want to hear gen Z's
yeah I was about to say how many are
followers followers actually want to
follow us I don't know some of them
might I can't I can't tell you what
they'll say to you it's uh but some of
them some of them might want to follow
you well I'm I'm on Tick Tock YouTube
Twitter Instagram all Harry Jason yeah
and you can come see me scream about how
jensy's gonna rip your throat out Harry
Sison at langley.com and then your Chris
Mowry at wafflehouse.gov it's Krista
raising.net it's Krista Mallory on on
Twitter and and Tick Tock and yeah just
scream people people think I'm acting I
just can't wait till like one day you
guys are like at Bohemian Grove
screaming into your phones
I respect the hell out of you guys for
coming on Nobody David Hogg won't come
on a lot of people will come on I
respect you guys for coming on I think
not enough people like as much as like I
really like Democrats and I like Joe
Biden not enough people will like just
go out they want to stay in the bubble
right they like about Joe but he's he's
a is he even alive does he even know
he's alive I mean he does what do you
like I mean I know some people like him
like Louis CK and me talk all the time
and Louie actually likes him but I mean
he's the kind of folksy and old I guess
that's cool but I mean at the end he's
he's productive right and he passes good
policy that's good for young people and
objectively good friends I think the
nuclear war will be great for you
there's nothing that young people are
gonna like more than the nuke then the
nuclear war Russia wouldn't be so stupid
they're not going to be that stupid I
hope they're not that stupid I I don't
think they are I agree with you okay I
hope you don't ground while the middle
ground is like I agree with the idea
that
um
the hope that this does not get there
and but I do think it's a foolhardy
policy that we are pursuing over there I
just I believe that and a lot of people
are now starting to believe that which
is why the American government bidens
government is actually starting to
question it internally and they're
they're leaking stuff and there's more
stuff coming out in the Press about like
if the spring offensive fails on the
side of the Ukraine you might have to
start pulling back we've given an
inordinate amount of money and resources
to this project and I think we're
starting to see now if that happens
people are going to ask a lot of
questions about why we spent all that
money and why that money wasn't used in
America
yeah I mean I think we just have to see
what happens and let it play out
um you know it's been proven time and
time again that Ukraine is doing a lot
better
than people thought
um and they date listen I will say one
thing about the Ukraine they're tougher
they're they're oh yeah [__] oh
yeah and I and listen I don't I didn't
want them to obviously be invaded and I
would love if Russia got out of there
and I'd love if everything worked out
and was peaceful I'm just looking at the
world as it is and not the way that I
would want it to be sure right well I
mean I know that those two countries
have a deep and complex history and it's
not as easy and there are you know there
are things in those countries that are
not it's not easy we can't throw it all
into a tick tock or a meme right now but
like I think it's forgotten that you
know that the however 44 billion or
however much money we've sent you grant
like that's the entire reason that you
know Russia is not knocking on Poland
right now right like no it's not yeah
it's all the West it's all the West it's
the greatest it's one of the greatest
the reality of the situation that that
arm in Ukraine is preventing Russia from
taking over the entire world is
I said they'd be knocking on the doors
of Poland if we didn't give them well we
all we with NATO expanding are
encircling Russia with missiles and if
we if that was being done to us if there
were countries putting if China had
missiles in Mexico you would be damn
sure we would respond I know but I don't
think like that's that's just like
objectively not looking at the fact that
like all those countries we started
expanding on their borders I mean
they're free to make their own decisions
they all asked to join NATO like it's
not we're not just we're not just but we
have to look at the purpose of what NATO
is right you have to look at what but
that necessarily how Russia will respond
to the real politic of like how Russia
will respond to certain things right
right and the reality is the purpose of
NATO was very clear after World War II
but is becoming a bit less clear right
now in the sense of you know what is the
cost benefit analysis of encircling a
nuclear power led by Vladimir Putin and
autocrat who wants to preserve his
sphere of influence in the world so
that's my but the thing about NATO is
like I think it's a little hyperbolic to
be so critical of NATO
um given the fact that NATO's entire
mission is peace like we're not
encircling Russia to be like haha we got
you now we're saying yes well there is
part of it listen NATO's entire issued
his peace as defined by the American
Empire meaning that peace peace meaning
the American Empire does whatever it
wants and countries like Russia don't
now that's fine coming from guys that
sit here in America but if you're
Vladimir Putin he's not looking at
NATO's Mission as being peace he's look
Russia is a country that's been
consistently invaded throughout their
history they they have bought many ads
on this show oh yeah and no but I'm
saying like I'm saying like at the end
of the day when you say NATO's mission
is peace that's [__] talking points
it's not lofty George Washington
University first year major crap that's
like saying America's mission is
democracy this isn't true it's control
it's power and if you're Vladimir Putin
and you're an autocrat you gotta deal
with you can't talk to Russia let me
talk to uh Iraq Russia is not Iraq yeah
you can't go in there put Putin in a
hole and you know here listen I like you
it's been a half hour
my new special Tim Dillon live from St
Petersburg uh we're selling tickets
right now it's hugely uh successful
we're doing it at the opera house where
they do the bolshei ballet which is it's
going to be beautiful and I'm very
excited there is a little bit of a
language barrier just a little bit um
I'm I'm uh obviously joking uh I'm on
the road timelcomedy.com follow Harry J
Sisson that's right and
chris.mauri Chris what dot dot Maori my
last name Mallory where Christophe Mary
on what tick tock tick tock and Twitter
you can see me get ratioed on Twitter oh
just destroy I'm gonna ratio you
something you could dude I'm gonna have
all my people no I mean listen it's
politics everybody's [__] nuts that's
the point right all right thank you guys
thank you